any business that I have
stems from six core values that I have.
now, core values are really,
really important to establish when you start a business.
one, because then you could be able to measure
performance based off of these core values.
you can hire based off of these core values
and you can fire based off these core values
and so we we want to have people in our companies
that fit these core values.
so No.1 is integrity.
of course, integrity
sounds like a really easy one that everybody has.
but it's imperative to who we are
and what we do.
No.2 is selflessness
and we want to be selfless in the things that we do.
three is transparency.
four is innovation.
five is excellence.
six is growth and development.
it's really important that we pursue all of
these things in our companies.
and they transcend all different aspects of my life, too.
I want somebody to be able to look at me,
measure my life
and measure how I perform in work upon these six things
and be able to hold me accountable to them.
that's how important these core values are.